bonjour nous sommes ici chez elisabeth
de feydeau une figure de la vie
versaillaise et je vous la présente en
quelques mots elle est docteur en
histoire spécialisé dans les parfums
elle cumule plusieurs métiers à savoir
écrivain créatrice d'une ligne de
bougies et conseil auprès de grandes
marques de parfumerie de luxe
voilà elisabeth merci nous accueillir
racault témoins peu d'où vient cette
passion de l'histoire est bien
l'histoire moi est ce parce que j'aimais
toutes les disciplines j'aimais beaucoup
la philosophie les lettres et c'est donc
pourquoi pas finalement s'intéresser à
l'histoire qui nous permet de cumuler
toutes ces disciplines que j'aimais et
puis très rapidement finalement c'est
arrivé sur le parfum
alors justement c'est aussi une passion
il ya eu un déclic particulier
racontez nous comment ça c'est comment
c'est venu cet amour du parfum et cet
intérêt alors l'amour du parfum est venu
en plusieurs temps il ya eu d'abord un
grand déclic à 16 ans quand j'ai
découvert un parfum très sélect qui a
fêté ses 100 ans cette année et qui m'a
absolument transportés r j'ai tellement
aimé cette odeur votre premier parfum
mon premier et qui est toujours mon
parfum
ah oui et donc j'ai tellement aimé cette
odeur j'ai voulu comprendre les arcanes
en fait de cette création pourquoi il y
avait un appel aussi fort pour cette
odeur d'accord mais c'est là où j'ai
découvert donc tout un art celui du
parent d'accord quand vous dites les
arcanes ça veut dire quoi exactement
en fait le par le parfum c'est un métier
très complexe pour un clic et qui fait
appel à beaucoup de disciplines à la
fois très technique mais aussi
artistique humaine tout simplement parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'humain dans le
parfum il y en a derrière tous les
créateurs les maisons qui qui vont
lancer des parfums régulièrement et puis
aussi les femmes et les hommes qui vont
porter ses parfums il ya une phrase
tellement jolie de jean giono qui dit
c'est écrire un français qui dit
finalement le parfum c'est l'odeur plus
l'homme parce que il faut pas oublier
que le parfum c'est avant tout une
histoire de rencontre et l heure à côté
moi vos différents ouvrages
comment ça a commencé donc vous avez
déjà écrit une biographie de juifs
argent qui était le parfumeur de marie
antoinette à 18
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à côté moi vos
recherches ben en fait tout a commencé
avec l'acteur
doctorat qui étaient ceux qui étaient
sur le parfum les athlètes utile et
exhale c'était de l'hygiène au rêve
l'industrie française du parfum donc nos
thèses de doctorat j'ai soutenu en
sorbonne et puis assez rapidement j'ai
eu un certain nombre de propositions
d'ouvragés en co signature il ya eu
france terre de luxe à la martinière il
ya eu également un livre qui s'appelle
l'indécence pour parler du parfum xxème
siècle qui est d'ailleurs ressorti ya
pas très longtemps
et puis vraiment le premier travail
d'écriture seul ça a été jean louis
farjon donc cette histoire de parfumeurs
qui avait été celui de marie antoinette
et qui avait vécu à paris mais bien sûr
beaucoup travaillé à la cour de la
cisaille voilà donc ça a été une
rencontre fabuleuse aussi beaucoup
beaucoup d'heures passées dans le
château de versailles à parcourir tous
ces petits appartements tous ces lieux
d'intimité comprendre justement comment
la reine vivait mais aussi qu'elle
pouvait être le regard posé par un
parent contemporain qui n'était pas de
la cour qui était un roturier qui était
un héros ni soeur donc voilà ça c'était
le premier travail qui a été pour moi
très déterminant et puis tout
dernièrement l'herbier de
marie-antoinette donc je suis revenu à
mes amours leurs impôts alors les amants
versailles est donc de l'odorat de l'olf
actifs au goût finalement il n'ya qu'un
pas qui est assez facile à franchir
et du coup je crois qu'en recherchant
les traces de jean lui farjon vous avez
eu la recette du fameux chocolats des
libertins paiement pour l'occasion là
vous allez nous proposer de d'assister à
la création à la re création de ce
fameux chocolat chez franck pommiers qui
est un chef versaillais et nous allons
voir donc les ingrédients hors du commun
qu'il utilise est le résultat de cette
recette on y va on y va
ces partiques rouler carrosse
nous voici donc maintenant arrivés dans
la cuisine de fonnier chef versaillais
et nous allons partir à la découverte de
ce dessert éphémères créés pour la saint
valentin
elisabeth alors c'est un dessert
historique
apparemment ce délice des libertins mais
ça a des serres historiques et
versailles elle puisque finalement il
été vues à la cour de versailles
c'était une recette que les east que les
libertins avait mis au point au xviiie
siècle et que louis 15 émane de
pompadour buvait comme un rituel
amoureux avant les transports d'alcôve
d'accord pourquoi parce que tu es en
fait ce rituel parce que le parfum de ce
chocolat parce qu'à l'époque le chocolat
qui était préparé à l'eau et est parfumé
selon l'humeur du jour selon les besoins
également des personnes et ce parfum
étaient réputées aphrodisiaques
il associait une crypte la vanille avec
du muscle et de lambres grille de
langres grille qu'est ce que c'est alors
lambres gris c'est pas très romantique
de dire ça malaisie éjection intestinale
du ch cachalot effectivement se taper
dessus ça que l'on pêche et que l'on
récupère pas que l'on pêche pas avec le
récupère sur les rivages de nouvelle
zélande nouvelle calédonie et caetera et
qui est que l'on découvre xviiie siècle
et qui transporte les contemporains
parce que c'est très éthéré c'est très
érotique ça en fait c'était viagra de
l'époque si vous voulez très bien que du
coup on associe aux muscles et à la
vanille pour parfumer le chocolat
d'accord donc la potion magique lé là
voilà alors c'était pas la potion de
l'époque
il a fallu le reconstituer donc j'étais
avec un arôme à titien pour recréer ce
parfum sous la forme d'un arômes
alimentaires que l'on peut aujourd'hui
utilisée dans une recette de chocolat
hockey et donc frank e mail nous allons
regarder ce que ça donne sous forme
d'émulsion si j'ai bien compris
pardon mais je vous en prie
voilà fait c'est une sorte de mousse de
chocolat très légère même pas et nous
savons en mission on est ce que du
chocolat chaud on veut pas ça pourrait
peut-être autre consistance quoi c est
alors si je connais la cérémonie leur
rôle alors à côté moi concède macaron
bleu et vous en prenez un problème est
donc grande buveuses de chocolat aussi
puisque elle prenait un chocolat tous
les matins au petit-déjeuner et le bleu
est en effet était une des fleurs
préférées de mentonnais qu'on trouve à
trianon et qui ornait la porcelaine de
sèvres de son service de doc le rappel
macarons double aig d'accord donc c'est
une fleurs comestibles
enfin je veux dire ça un apport au
niveau du goût vous allez voir c'est
super on va voir roger at on y va
elizabeth
oui et puis ça rappelle aussi qu'à
l'époque au potager du roi il y avait
tout ce qu'on appelait les fournitures à
salade qui étaient des herbes
aromatiques qu'on mettait dans les
salades en les potages la cuisine était
très varié et parfumée à l'époque
d'accord donc ce dessert il est à
déguster en amoureux on trempe voilà on
partage nos résolutions de chocolat
d'accord on a fait quelque chose de très
légères oui je veux le secret dans la
gale c'est bon au divin bravo franck
nos travaux franck des yeux franck bravo
on s'est régalé le voyage valait le
détour
on vous quitte à bientôt nous voici
repartis chez lisa bête pour la suite de
notre entretien
voilà alors elizabeth
nous sommes de retour chez vous vous
voyez et nous allons pouvoir enfin
évoqué ces fameuses bougies
racontez-moi alors la bougie des
libertins dont nous avons évoqué les
senteurs à travers le dessert que nous
avons découvert tout à l'heure comment
vous est venue l'idée de sa création
justement en boutons ce chocolat qu'on
avait reconstitué
il ya déjà quelques années au moment du
livre et je trouvais cette odeur
tellement fabuleuse que j'ai voulu
recréer le parfum du chocolat donc cette
triple vanille cet ambre gris et se
muscle comment on fait concrètement pour
pour imaginer l'odeur de quelque chose
qui se mange comment on peut transmettre
ça parce que je passe à doit pas être
évident quand il ya des formules comme
ça cependant il ya pas de formules en
fait on sent les choses on connaît les
matières premières qui entrent dans
l'odeur que vous avez en tête et ensuite
on travaille pas à pinces et des allers
retours avec le laboratoire et les
parfumeurs qui me font des soumissions
et je corrige jusqu'à ce que j'obtienne
l'odeur que j'ai dans ma mémoire en fait
si vous voulez d'accord du coup quand
les choses sont l'un et bien c'est bon
c'est voilà résultat alors à côté moi
donc les autres bougies finalement vous
allez nous nous offrait à travers elles
différentes ambiances du quotidien
quelques pages de marie antoinette
je pense à celle qui s'appelle fin qui
vous a rappelé une odeur particulière
quand vous visitez le château alors oui
mais bougival évoqué bas tout le
prestige du château de versailles
et puis l'art de vivre du xviiie siècle
a tellement été admirés et qui
continuent d'ailleurs cela par le monde
entier alors une des mes premières
créations dans cette collection c'était
une bougie qui me rappeler l'odeur du
lundi à la voile à l'odeur d'huile dans
les grès dans l'odeur du lundi quand il
évoque ses lâches côté borloo est en
fait c'est que le lundi le château est
fermé d'accord donc on en caustique avec
une recette originale qui est très
miellé qui est très végétal
on va en cause ce ticket les planchers
et sa mère moi je traînais dans les
couloirs de versailles
souvent le lundi pour m'inspirer et pour
comprendre aussi les arcanes de ce
palais j'avais cette odeur entente avec
de temps en temps des petites notes de
feu de boire comme s'il y avait eu
encore un feu ce qui n'est évidemment
pas le cas ouais
et du coup c'est une odeur que j'aimais
tellement et comme j'utilise beaucoup de
bougies parfumées dans mon travail
d'écriture
je voulais retrouver cette odeur donc
c'était obsessionnel et on a travaillé
travaillé jusqu'à ce qu'à un moment
donné
l'odeur du lundi soit la sueur surtout -
là d'accord quels sont vos anecdotes
olfactives à vous en fait servi au
château de versailles ont créé des
bonnes odeurs pour cacher les mauvaises
voilà ce qui était aussi le signe d'un
grand raffinement
donc il ya une odeur amusante
à propos des jardins et des bosquets de
versailles c'est que beaucoup de gens
qui vivent à versailles et les personnes
ont des besoins humains et donc que bah
voilà les choses se faisait un peu
partout et du coup on utilisé dans les
parterres de l'onho beaucoup de fleurs
blanches qui ont la particularité
d'avoir des odeurs très forte très
couvrante on va dire et c'est pour ça
qu'on retrouvait à l'époque de lenôtre
dans les parterres énormément de jasmin
il est bête j'ai l'impression que
finalement votre doha est toujours en
éveil toujours absolument tout suis pas
là faisant ça peut être fatigant savez
quand tu disais que le plus le sens le
plus difficile
voyez le contraire à la liberté c'était
celui de l'odorat parce qu'on peut pas
se boucher le nez mais les activement
donc c'est beau ça et c'est important
parce que l'odorat est un sens
contrairement aux autres sens qui ne
décline pas avec l'âge de la vie à on ne
perd pas son odorat comme on peut perdre
l'ouïe ou la vallée on peut le perdre la
soirée c'est une pathologie mais le tort
les personnes sont doués de derain
puisque c'est le premier sens qui se
développe à la naissance le nourrisson
reconnaît sa mère à son odeur et ensuite
on a tout le temps cette odorat puisque
à l'origine doha était le sens qui nous
alerter du danger
donc il est important que ce que
l'odorat reste vivace si vous voulez
tout au long de la vie mais comme on ne
travaille pas le dorat comme on ne
muscles pas nos narines et ben on
l'oubli on oublie qu'on a un nez au
milieu du visage d'accord et vous alors
vous travaillez votre doha régulièrement
vous faites vos gammes mais bon on fait
je fais mes gammes exactement comme un
musicien fait ses gammes il faut
apprendre à reconnaître les odeurs il
faut sentir apprendre à sentir et
ressentir ces trois étapes celui qui
sont très importants et qui ressent tire
ça veut dire coin et bien ressentir de
la joie de la ba oui c'est l'émotion
exaltant fonction de l'odeur tout à fait
l'émotion arrive donc je pense que le
drap est un sens du bonheur parce que
finalement c'est très joyeux de
ressentir la vie au travers de toutes
les odeurs qu'elle nous offre
elisabeth de feydeau merci merci à vous
et puis à très bientôt j'espère j'espère
aussi au revoir au revoir et à bientôt